hey wisecrack Jared again with a new
Rick and Morty season supposedly just
around the corner we thought that it
would be a great time to revisit one of
our favorite episodes get schwifty gives
you updates a jam one of the show's
essential features is that it
trivializes everything people hold dear
and for billions of people nothing is
more sacred than religion while religion
is rather overtly a regular victim of
Rick's contempt yes there's something to
be said about the complexity of the
schwifty episode while Rick and Morty
often reduces religion to superstition
there is no God summer gotta rip that
band-aid off now you'll thank me later
get schwifty complicates this outlook
exploring the way we rationalize such
things
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of get schwifty when a giant
floating head shows up and insists to
humanity show me what you got
the earth is plagued with earthquakes
sinkholes
fires and massive flooding the show uses
this opportunity to quickly roast the
opportunistic nature of organized
religion giant heads are destroying the
world but the church needs more faith
more money and a new church organ sanity
has been restored to this assembly I'd
like to talk about the cost of preparing
our new organ but it doesn't dwell there
the episode follows two groups there are
those that know that the Kremlin's are
actually there to film a reality show
this head won't go away until shows them
it's got a head and those that have no
clue what is going on it's a guy
if it's God do we get out of school head
ism is a cult that pops up because of a
cosmic problem in point of view there's
no peek behind the curtain people don't
know what the hell of chrome Yulin is or
what show me what you got refers to show
me what you got so naturally they form a
cult the episode could be read is just a
scathing indictment of religion about
the arbitrary nature of faith and its
ceremonies like on Ascension Day the
head is sent unwanted oils to the gods
which bears a striking resemblance to
the crucifixion of Christ instead what
is presented as something much more
complex the episode takes aim at the
reasoning behind belief structures
themselves not just religious practices
it exposes the fallacies behind all
kinds of [ __ ] people believe get
schwifty makes fun of two common logical
fallacies both of which complete
correlation with causation the headus
religion is started because principal
vagina prays to the head at the same
time that the cataclysmic events begin
to subside that's known as the Combe hoc
ergo propter hoc fallacy the mistaken
belief that one thing occurring at the
same time as another unrelated thing has
anything to do with each other
the reality is the head stopped because
they are pleased with Rick's impromptu
performance of get schwifty a song about
dropping your panties and a deuce on the
floor now if your pants and your panties
[ __ ] on the floor
time to get swifty in here I like what
you got good job
the person to create the first list of
logical fallacies was Aristotle tired of
arguing with dumb people he created a
giant list of arguments that sounded
great but are actually pure ass clownery
the episode plays with all sorts of
these fallacies the president thinks
that the dream Billy Corgan Randy Newman
and Pharrell are all dead because
they're all dead but how is that
possible do people just die when I name
them that's the post hoc ergo propter
hoc fallacy the idea that because
something comes prior to something else
it is naturally the cause principal
vagina tries to ascend Beth and Jerry
and everybody assumes that this angers
the heads
that's the Combe hoc ergo propter hoc
fallacy again in reality the heads are
actually pissed off because Rick's
performance without Morty is terrible
that end a nuclear strike so the head is
try to ascend principal vagina to ease
the heads anger but truth is the heads
don't give a rat's ass about what
they're up to
in each instance the characters with a
limited point of view the people who
don't know that oh this is just a giant
reality TV show believe that their
mundane ceremonies actually influence
the heads Beth and Jerry actually point
out this logical fallacy a couple times
it's possible that we may have been
correlating some things that weren't
actually related at all I'm just saying
we don't know there's a cause-effect
relationship while ruthlessly satirizing
the magical thinking of the faithful the
episode also makes a greater point
people don't just fall into silly
beliefs out of pure irrationality rather
they over rationalize their thinking to
the point of absurdity some cognitive
psychologists argue that pseudo
scientific belief systems are far from
fragile doomsday cults psychics and
conspiracy theorists are also resilient
in their beliefs because they are
sustained by the structure of the human
brain the belief systems persistent
spread via appeals to rationality not
through tricking people or the stupidity
of the masses the human brain is
hardwired to search for logical
conclusions and easy explanations how is
praying going to
ma'am a giant head in the skies
controlling the weapon did you want to
play checkers let's be rational I'll see
it people tend to believe what they want
to believe what lines up with their
worldview people like consuming and
sharing news that aligns with their
political beliefs or creating elaborate
justifications for supporting the sports
scene they were raised to root for
it's called confirmation bias the
propensity to seek out and interpret
information that proves your own beliefs
confirmation bias explains why people
are willing to overcome glaring flaws in
their belief system for the sake of
personal benefit summer is doing really
well here she's not getting pregnant or
doing drugs or missing curfew please
help me you can reach me if you try
that's not our business as long as
summer is thriving
all of these fallacies and biases aren't
unique to religion though while Rick and
Morty has a great time [ __ ] on
religion the reality is that post hoc
rationalization is an inevitability of
our cause and effect thought process
even the audience is fooled by the
brains tendency to accept logical
fallacies as seen in Rick's snake and
wristwatch trick stay back this watch
turns people into snakes
stand out everybody stand down it plays
on the brains desire to tribute event a
as the cause of event beat when in
reality why didn't he turn into a snake
trade secret mr. president particle beam
in a wristwatch snake holster on the leg
sure Rick and Morty delivers the tasty
irony that the cosmic events that help
build a religion can be woefully
inaccurate that the reality of belief
structures can be built on the most
inane of all things a [ __ ] reality TV
show but they take things a step further
the ability to make predictions and
understand the complexity of existence
as a whole is taken to task and that's
what separates Rick and Morty from
contemporary satire nothing is safe not
even belief
take it easy wisecrack hey guys thanks
for watching I really hope you liked
that we got a bunch more Rick and Morty
videos on the channel so click here to
jump through this portal and check out
our Rick and Morty playlist the idea to
do this video came from the comments
from you guys you guys said that you
wanted to do a breakdown of each Rick
and Morty episode so we said hey let's
try it so if you have another idea for a
smart video you'd like us to make let us
know by using hashtag hey wisecrack in
your comments and we'll take a look
through them and see what you guys want
and be sure to check out our patreon
page pledges help support the team that
puts in the really hard work to bring
these videos to life so go to our
patreon page at patreon.com slash
wisecrack and if you sign up this month
you'll get access to a video that we
made that was literally too hot for
YouTube it was up for about six hours it
was actually about pornography I
actually think it was one of our better
8-bit philosophy episodes but
unfortunately there's a little bit too
risque for YouTube so if you become a
patron you can check it out plus for
every new patron we get this month I
promise we'll give our office dog woody
a big ol hug promise so click here to
watch the Ricky Morty playlist click
here to support us on patreon and if you
have a video idea for us leave a comment
with hashtag hay wisecrack got a rod and
we've got a ton more videos to work on
thanks a lot for all the support guys
love you all peace
[Music]
you